hey guys it's justine and today's video
is going to be a follow-up video to a
video that i did a while ago it was on
the insta 360 go to i'm sure you've seen
some of my videos featuring some of the
insta 360 cameras but this one is very
special and the first one came out maybe
like a year almost two-ish years ago
this one's been out for a few months now
this is the insta 360 go 2. this is it
this is a camera it comes in this little
case and this is the camera it pops out
just like this it actually has an nd
filter on it which those are something
new that they recently released so they
come in this little case so you can just
screw these off
and on
oh i dropped it this will give you such
a better image when you're shooting in
really bright light conditions and i
noticed a huge difference the first time
that i tried this in the car just doing
some driving shots when i was testing it
out so this little camera connects to
the little case this case will charge it
you can also plug this into your
computer using usb c 2a and you'll be
able to mount this like an external
drive and you can just copy all of the
files on here that you shoot the cool
thing is you can be using this as a
remote though because it does use
bluetooth i can place this somewhere
random like up here in the corner use
this to record this connects to the
camera so you can change various
settings you can do time lapses
hyperlapses you can shoot photos you can
shoot the pro mode video which is really
cool because it basically is shooting
kind of like a 180 view and then it
takes that 180 view and it uses flow
state stabilization to stabilize the
image and it gives you this super smooth
look that it's almost like if you're
holding this out here and walking it's
kind of like a drone is following you i
also
love that this connects to the insta360
app and you're able to just kind of edit
this content on the go and i love being
able to do that this video was a little
bit different because i actually had a
couple of these i was filming a ton of
content all the time so i was
transferring the footage from these to
my computer then bringing that footage
into the insta360 studio exporting those
out and then editing them in final cut
which is kind of a long process but
really once you kind of get the workflow
down with this kind of figure out the
controls because i'm not going to lie
like when you first get this it feels
very confusing and i have spent so much
time with this that this camera feels
like second nature to me if you do have
it connected to
this little controller into the case
obviously it's easy to tell what's
happening but you can program the
different types of i guess button
presses inside of the app so if i do
one press this will automatically start
capturing pro video but if i do two
presses of the button it'll start doing
a time lapse and why i love this is what
i've been doing this entire trip is i've
been wearing this necklace and this is a
really cool little accessory it's a
magnetic necklace and since this little
camera is also magnetic i've kept this
case in my pocket i basically have had
this necklace on and you just kind of
wear it right under your shirt and you
can attach the camera just like this
the first thing that you're going to
notice is doesn't really doesn't really
look cool
i mean i guess if you want to define
what cool is if i saw this i would think
you were cool but maybe the general
public might be a little bit confused
but i have had a lot of conversations
with people randomly on the trail
they're like what is that it's a camera
this is where it's so cool because it is
so easily accessible right here if i
want to start filming something i just
go like this
i'm now filming and it gives you this
kind of hectic feedback like a little
vibration so i know that it's recording
and then when i hit it again
it gives you kind of like a long
vibration so you know that it has
stopped recording and why i love having
it just easily accessible right here is
even if i see something happening i just
grab it off my necklace
i hit the button i start recording and i
don't miss the shot and since i made my
first unboxing video they have come out
with a few more accessories they have
one that you can attach to like a gopro
mount so that this will be encased
inside of an outer case so it won't go
anywhere but i unfortunately did not
bring any gopro
mount pieces to hawaii and you know
what's kind of crazy you can't find any
on the island because i feel like that
is one of the most purchased things here
because everyone is out doing water
sports i couldn't find any and then the
one that i ordered online and just i
don't know where it went it never showed
up so that wasn't something that i got
to test but what i did get the test was
a head mount so it's like this little
hat mount that i was able to wear so it
gives you kind of like this cool
downward perspective so when i was
hiking i could see my feet and then kind
of like my body super strange but really
cool but most of the time this is what i
was doing so i want to show you guys how
i've been using this camera i have it
attached to the magnetic necklace and as
i'm walking i just go boop i hit it i've
got it set to do pro video recording
and now i'm filming and a lot of times
i'll just go like this
grab it off the necklace
hold it up get some shots i also have a
bunch of accessories that i've been
using with it as well but this has been
the main kind of go-to
just just like that this other little
accessory that i've really been loving
is this which will attach to like a
little tripod mount there's also a
really cool mount that has a little
sticky on the back of it so i've been
using that in the car to get driving
shots or shots of me driving and it's
great because i'm able to also capture
something that is happening randomly
outside very quick another accessory
that is really cool hold on a second
this
is a very very very very long pool that
insta360 has and this i was out i guess
kind of trying to get some some sea
turtle action this was so cool because i
was able to attach this little tripod
mount to that stick and i put it in the
water and i even saw i think it was an
octopus or a squid i'm not sure i saw a
little leggy a little tentacle let me
know if you know what this is and it's
cool because the actual camera itself is
waterproof so you are able to submerge
that into water but the one thing that
isn't waterproof is the case so just be
careful if you do happen to put this in
water just make sure it's completely
dried off before you put it back in the
case we also have this other smaller
insta 360 selfie stick which you can see
i'm using here on this hike because it
does kind of give you that opportunity
to reach out further see more things i
also loved doing this shot where i kind
of put it behind me so it sort of looked
like the camera was following me or
somebody else was filming me but really
i was just holding the stick behind me
so now i guess i'll take you into the
vlog portion of this footage all of this
was shot on the insta360 go to i hope
that you guys enjoy it because i had so
much fun filming this and editing it
[Music]
i'm not a light packer at all
made it to the airport
traditional mix
[Music]
hey
jenna has had over a 20-hour travel day
i'm sleepy she's sleepy
[Music]
dude the car is not starting are you
freaking
kidding unfortunately i'm very familiar
with this type of thing see that
look at that
round two let's
hope for the best
[Music]
yes
[Applause]
[Music]
this is the secret beach at cool ranch
it's so freaking beautiful the sun just
came up it's absolutely just it's a
freaking dream
[Music]
i got up at 3am to catch the sunrise
we're hopping on a boat in a small boat
let's hope that we don't get to sick
we're not we're fine
[Music]
we're about to do the coco head crater
hike it's a thousand stairs all the way
up to the top and then you have to come
back down
this is where it's a little iffy because
you have to go across these railroad
ties you
slip you fall i remember the first time
i did this i cried
[Music]
didn't check the weather no it's not
raining pretty normal occurrence in
hawaii though carry on
[Music]
and we did it
on our way back down
[Music]
just finished the hike and i've done
this hike so many times and they're
actually doing some restoration to it so
i will definitely be donating to their
gofundme because this hike actually is
it's improved significantly with all the
added little extras that they put in
[Music]
we're at cool little ranch and this is
one of my most favorite places in oahu
it's a 4 000 acre private ranch
[Music]
do you also hide to my hat
i'm testing out hat cam today like look
i'm looking down i'm looking up looking
all around
[Music]
i'm so excited this is one of my
favorite shave ice places here in the
island it is so good unpiped
thank you
check this out
[Music]
off we go this is about a five plus mile
adventure that we're about to embark on
[Applause]
ow oh so sorry we are about halfway up
to the first place that we need to go
and then there's another spot why are
you not sweating
am i not sweaty
i feel it i'm like
[Music]
hope you guys enjoyed this follow-up
video with insta360 go this camera has
been so much fun to use and even since
the day that it came out even since the
first version of this i knew that the
second version was gonna be awesome and
it has not disappointed me since a huge
thank you to insta360 for sponsoring
this video they have always been so
supportive of my channel and i've been
such a huge fan of their cameras like
don't tell them that i would have done
this video for free but the fact that
they did sponsor this
thank you i appreciate it
thank you guys so much for watching i'll
see you in the next video bye
[Music]